dr. sleepers apparently a cinematic
awakening after attending an exclusive
screening for the latest Stephen King
can obtain a head of its November
release critics have flooded Twitter
with their thoughts on dr. sleep so far
reactions are extraordinarily positive a
sequel to King's seminal novel The
Shining which was itself adapted into a
classic film by Stanley Kubrick in 1980
director Mike Flanagan stalked asleep
follows an adult Danny Torrance played
by Ewan McGregor the grown-up Danny is
revealed to still be haunted by his
childhood ability known as The Shining
which includes visions and other psychic
happenings though he desperately wants
to live a normal life and establish some
sorts of peace for himself Danny is
still traumatized by what's happened to
him as a child at the shining haunted
Overlook Hotel things only get more
complicated when he meets children who
share his special gift namely a girl
named Abra who asks for Danny's
protection against cult leader rose the
hats and her underlings his fears have
never been greater but Danny knows he
must do everything in his power to
protect Abra and other children with the
shine from forces of evil only met two
or three people like us they died
before we get to how the critics feel
about dr. sleep we should reveal what
the most important reviewer has to say
Stephen King himself took to Twitter to
share his infilled hurt feelings toward
dr. sleep and his reaction was totally
positive praising the big-screen
adaptation of his 2013 novel king called
dr. sleep an immersive experience and
commended director Flanagan for his
storytelling skills King tweeted dr.
sleep Mike Flanagan is a talented
director but he's also an excellent
storyteller the movie is a good thing
you'll like this if you like the shining
but you'll also like it if you liked
Shawshank king is no stranger to
adaptations of his work but this is high
praise coming from the author who
famously disliked Kubrick's take on the
shining in fact a king infamously
compared the film which he called cold
to a quote big beautiful Cadillac with
no engine inside it now on to the
critics who have no personal stake in
the worlds of the shining and a
successor
dr. sleep the daily dead news had the
wixen had nothing but praise for dr.
sleep tweeting it's been a great year
for Stephen King Gallup tations but I
think dr. sleep is the best of the bunch
thrilled me in ways I wasn't expecting
maybe emotional at times and Rebecca
Ferguson is ferocious what a wonderful
celebration of Kubrick King and
Flanagan's career as well cinema blends
senior film critic Eric Eisenberg was
also all in on dr. sleep which is saying
something considering he's a
self-proclaimed shining fanatic King die
hard and Mike Flanagan enthusiast
Eisenberg tweeted has a huge fan of
Kubrick's The Shining a king's books and
Mike Flanagan I'm giddy that dr. sleep
is seriously grace it's an excellent and
faithful adaptation that makes smart
changes especially melding the 80 film
and the sequel book and the casting
performances are phenomenal Jacob Hall
managing editor at slash film also
adored the movie he wrote in a tweet dr.
sleep the boldest choice here is that
Mike Flanagan doesn't even try to do
Kubrick he makes a Mike Flanagan movie
spooky emotional ultimately optimistic
not only a sequel to the shining but a
response to it an attempt to reconcile
King and Kubrick loved it the
performances in dr. sleeve were also
highlighted by critics including comic
book coms
Brandon
davus he tweeted fans of the shining are
really gonna love dr. sleep it's at its
best when it's fueled by follow-up start
slowly and descends into madness just
like its predecessor one specific scene
is really horrifying some solid scares
and good performances across the board
though the vast majority of critics
can't say enough good things about dr.
sleep one didn't feel completely blown
away by it yes I do love movies creator
John Duarte admitted in a tweet that he
was a bit underwhelmed by the film he
tweeted dr. sleep is a good movie but
didn't Wow me like writer director Mike
son against previous work overall though
it looks like fans of Stephen King's
novel and Stanley Kubrick's The Shining
need not worry Flannigan his cast and
his crew have apparently created a
sequel that does justice to both its
source material and the cinematic
predecessor dr. sleep arrives in
theaters on November 8th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]